a human tragedy of unspeakable
proportions unfolded in the night of the
19th to 20th of April of the Libyan
coast south of lamb producer the
combined effort of rescue teams from
Italy and Malta could only save 27 lives
out of an estimated 800 people including
many women and children a few days
before 400 migrants died in another
shipwreck Donald Tusk the president of
the european council declared that it
cannot continue like this we cannot
accept that hundreds of people died when
trying to cross the sea to Europe this
is why I have decided to call an
extraordinary european council this
thursday the summit will discuss at the
highest EU level what more you member
states and EU institutions can do
together concretely and immediately the
first priority is to save lives EU
leaders will discuss how to rapidly
reinforce operation try it on with more
rescue teams more vessels and
helicopters and a wider area of
operation member states must also look
at how best to provide international
protection to those in the region who
need it and how to better organize the
return home of unauthorized economic
migrants it is also urgent to stop the
criminal networks of smugglers and
traffickers who earn money by exploiting
desperate migrants leaders will explore
ways to do this including the possible
destruction of traffickers boats with
military means based on the experience
of counter-piracy operation Atalanta of
the somali coast i do not expect any
quick fix solutions to the root causes
of migration because Stalin had they
existed we would have used them long ago
it concerns all of us all of Europe
that's why we need to act and act
together now
you